Often acquiring data to do analysis doesn't require
any particularly fancy methodology. It's just a matter of
finding the right file somewhere on the internet
and downloading it. A lot of the data that
exists out there, particularly on government websites, is
stored in text files. For example, let's say we
wanted to get a database of all major league baseball statistics. I kind find
this data at http://www.SeanLahman.com/baseballarchives/statistics.
If I visit this website, I can see that
the data I want is available in a variety
of formats. A comma delimited or CSV version, but
also a Microsoft Access version, and a SQL version.